[Music]
okay just got done seeing that one
called the dead don't die which was an
ensemble cast all-star cast zombie movie
slash comedy and Bill Murray was in it
like in Tom Waits was in an Iggy Pop was
in it every was it him Adam driver he
was in it couldn't yeah alright
everybody you know likes in this damn
shit's [ __ ] hilarious
it was sucking hilarious the entire
audience was just rolling this the tone
is kind of like kind of like return to
the Living Dead remember that me yeah
and I don't like death but a lot more of
a drier sense of humor very self-aware I
mean I don't want to steal anything
yes Thunderdome so I'm not a sayin
engine just if you like MST you know
three thousand RiffTrax if you like
horror movies that you like B movies you
know plan 9 from outer space you would
love this [ __ ] movie if you like
Ghostbusters you'd love it I was gonna
like it's it's kind of like it almost
it's a similar system you know to maybe
zombie land with Phil Murray also
Ghostbusters a little bit like what's
the one I was thinking of Shana be dead
oh yeah yeah but I mean it's directed by
Jim Jarmusch which if you've seen any of
this other remedies for texia most of
his other ones um it has like a very
similar Trevor that's like I said very
dry very meta yeah you know it's it's
very it's just kind of looks this really
funny setup it's like what if there was
a zombie apocalypse and it was just this
tiny little town and you know know where
middle America or whatever and
everyone's just kind of like it's a sort
of low-key yeah it's like this dry sense
humor this totally ridiculous saying he
should have in it but well that's movie
Contagion
hilarious it's like like all this crazy
[ __ ] was happening everyone was like
yeah the script script was very good it
was tight um it it was placed in a place
called Centreville that yeah senator
bill which is kind of like basing middle
America town you know we're doing a lot
of like references callbacks Direction
[ __ ] and and it was funny is like at
certain opportune times you get the can
John John Carter John Carpenter [ __ ]
score in the backgrounds do you know
yeah yes start doing it was so much if
this is one of those ones were I feel
like I have to see it like a bunch more
time there's a bunch of stuff is hidden
in there one thing that actually really
made me last like the last I haven't
seen um Jim Jarmusch's movie that came
out 2014 which was only lovers left
alive and everybody is like recommended
that's me if I ever get the last one who
does that I saw was coffee and
cigarettes which a 2003 and I saw that
movie theater and that's why I kind of
laughed because when Iggy Pop things
back is the vampire he's like coffee he
was in company and said yeah it's
definitely one of my baguette on blu-ray
and add to the collection this is a good
one I really really like this it was
just it was hysterical but like I said
it's not like wacky it's like yeah like
the situation is crazy but everybody is
like just got a slight except like under
reacting to it which it makes it even
funnier I'm gonna say I'm gonna say for
the genre and what they attempted to do
I'm gonna give it a 10 out of 10
yeah I thought it was hilarious and yeah
we actually saw it it doesn't start
officially I think for two more days
early it was like an early opening a bit
like a couple days early and it was
almost full yeah everybody in there was
using diet if you're not an analyst or
anything like this this is one that'd be
worth worth clicking the theaters seeing
it in a theater with with an audience
it's just stuck the hilarious yeah yeah
just yeah but it's still kind of like
respectable zombie movie in a way with
some weird [ __ ] that it's just you got
to see it for yourself I don't want to
steal it boots Thunder yeah
you
we saw two of them today first one we
saw was RiffTrax it was what was the
name of that movie star star Raiders man
start that guy okay RiffTrax you know
they place shitty movies kind of like
MST in case you don't know if it's
shitty movie lives shitty movies live
they stream it to the theater and they
riff on and it was pretty good and then
the movie sucked
[ __ ] terrible it was a new movie it
was like 18 months old yeah yeah this is
2018 yeah dude that was in Starship
Troopers
yeah Casper Van Dien yes yeah starred in
it I don't know like what bet he lost to
be in this [ __ ] it was supposed to be
like holy crap let's be kind of like a
like a Flash Gordon spinoff they had
Flash Gordon style rocket ships and
stuff in a way mixed with [ __ ] crap
and oh man I mean the problem with a
move is too much dialogue too much dolly
the bad edit just bad everything I mean
this made this made an asylum flick look
like a [ __ ] yeah this was like okay
one it was like somebody clearly did
this [ __ ] in [ __ ] after-effects yeah
everything was Green screamed badly like
all the backgrounds and everything all
the ships are greens got all the
explosions were just like standard
things that come with your film editing
programs all the costumes were got off
the rag head bomb shrine ebay from a
Halloween store or they had got them
from shrine yeah very very obvious yeah
I've seen a lot of those clothes like
average yeah and the corsets at the
moment and the with the funny is that it
did have potential I mean some of the
masks looked cool some of the bad guys
kind of looked cool I mean
Skeletor some of the shitty b-movie some
of the shitty B movies that I grew up
with you know I mean actually we're
probably done with less technology you
know you know what I mean and maybe like
less of a budget probably I'd be curious
but they were more fun yeah but there
was more more fun to watch I mean this
is more like cosplayers out out in the
woods but the guy the guys were riffing
on it and it was [ __ ] funny you
couldn't follow the story so you just
had to just roll with it
listen to the jokes because I have I
don't think anybody recommend RiffTrax
it's a fun night to come see rib tracks
you know you guys that watch the show
you know I love MST and you know
RiffTrax is three of the guys from MST
and yeah another one in August they're
doing giant spider invasion yeah I saw
that one in the theater when I was a kid
my dad took me to it man terrified me
that's the one with all the tarantulas
and the big spider on the Volkswagen is
clearly a Volkswagen Network yeah that's
good yeah but yeah RiffTrax is always
yes super super fun recommended so even
though the movies are painfully bad
usually yeah this one I actually was
entertained by this one just because I
couldn't believe how shitty it was and
they actually got a person that was sort
of famous to be in it it's kind of like
member star crash star crash is even
better star crash yes star crashes and
battle beyond the stars was a lot better
yeah but it was like as it was but it
was a similar kind of thing like these
cheap-ass costumes and just like
obviously somebody tried to come up with
so it was like a bad D&D campaign and
it's like way too complicated and nobody
had any idea what's going on
yeah
you
okay just got back from seeing uh what
was an x-men dark dark meeting it was a
well made a well made movie I wouldn't
call it a bad movie but I didn't enjoy
it very much and I was kind of wanting
it to be over
my gripes with it were it seemed to be
set in the 90s I think it was 1992 okay
my guys win it was that the x-men
themselves look fake they looked they
look very fake especially in broad
daylight they looked a little bit better
in good lighting
yeah but it definitely just you know you
could tell that that was masks and
[ __ ] costumes and [ __ ] and another
thing about the movie is that the movie
was a fruit it's slow it's a long movie
and it's very slow at certain spots very
overly dramatic and kind of drug it kind
of was dragging on for me now in the end
he kind of had some superhero fights
that were kind of a payoff that you sat
through it at least but and you got to
see something at the end but overall the
movie I thought was just kind of a drag
I didn't really like it you know what's
interesting is that I think I might have
only seen the first x-men movie and that
was like a long time ago so this is
pretty much I mean I'm coming into it
like I know kind of generally the story
of the x-men and all the other stuff but
so I can't it kind of came into this
sort of I actually didn't find this
movie um I liked it better than Captain
Marvel I liked it but I might have liked
it a little bit better than anything
although you know at the end you know
Jean Grey's flying around with all the
[ __ ] fire out of it looked a lot like
Captain Marvel she basically became
Captain Marvel yeah the thing about like
it being like a much more dramatic story
I actually kind of liked that better
than just like constant superhero
punching because I feel like that gets
stupid after a while
was there was like some of there was
some like superhero fights in this that
were like pretty cool and stuff but I
liked that I liked the more character
drama because I liked James McAvoy and I
liked Michael Fassbender and yeah they
do pretty much good and everything yeah
they're good and the rest the rest of
the actors in the movie I don't think
I'm gonna say the actors because the
dude that played nuts was in it I liked
that guy but the character they had him
plan I just thought it was kind of
lackluster the mood the whole he didn't
have a lot to do even have a lot to knit
much the movie was to me was like it was
lacking it was kind of like that it's
like a lackluster not fun to watch and
the the characters were not fun it's
kind of sad it's sad characters are not
we're not really charming to me I didn't
really remember like it like for
instance and then some of them kind of
later on and it was like yeah okay I
kinda liked that character like the guy
that the Nightcrawler their version the
Nightcrawler yeah yeah I didn't like him
at first now in the end when I saw him
when he finally kind of manned up in
desmos [ __ ] and I was like yeah right
that that was alright but it didn't that
that character didn't look real and that
character supposed to be German or
Austrian or something just have a really
thick German accent and to me he just
had an Indian accent it was it didn't
seem and he didn't really look right
that character was always drawn is just
like a damn black silhouette with eyes
and fangs you know I mean he look like a
demon from hell
and the way they got him looking he just
kind of looked like a skinny blue guy
with a tail and the tail look rubber to
me it's just just a fake it's the fake
I don't like superhero movies anyway
it's not my it's not my favorite genre
but I didn't like this one better than
some of the other ones we've seen but
for that reason because it seemed to
have like a little bit more substance to
it no wasn't I like and honestly I liked
that they didn't I tend to like DC a
little bit more because it's a little
bit more rooted in realism you know I
mean guys that just have money like that
man money and a bunch of tools and
training yeah
Joker just a [ __ ] insane terrorist
you know I'm more into that kind of
stuff movie looks like
we saw preview for that but some of this
some of this Marvel shit's a little bit
too over-the-top for me even the [ __ ]
Aquaman is over-the-top funny well they
knew this goofy there's like Flash
Gordon but would I recommend this one
yeah maybe if you like superhero movies
you might like okay lately
yeah not better than like Shazam or
anything she's amaz must kicked ass but
that was like but that was more comedy
this was definitely not that's the tone
I like better this is more like it down
taking a soft serious no humor
[Music]